today on our show going into Gaza when
they go bad man right man we're going to
snap together our review of the Lego
Batman movie today on fat man on Lego
Batman
welcome to Batman Batman I'm Kevin Smith
I am of monarda we're going to [ __ ]
talk the [ __ ] out of Lego the Lego
Batman movie
yeah with Will Arnett which we both seen
yeah I went to the premiere for a new
Jeep a like a [ __ ] army I paid like a
Mook but it was the second time I
thought oh I'll tell you about the first
time I said oh my god so he's seen it
twice so you're gonna get this [ __ ]
[ __ ] broken down we all had a weekend to
see it and stuff did it open well it
open very well there you go
no uh you know we're johnny-come-lately
to it but a lot of people like what the
[ __ ] the show has Batman in the title
aren't you going to review get off your
fat ass bah blah blah and so here we are
looking for we do that bit of
housekeeping folks in order to keep the
lights on
mmm we got some paid advertisements here
now when I'm a paid man they do give us
money for this I'll give a [ __ ] I wear
this [ __ ] free for nothing man we're
talking about me and E's dot-com man me
undies calm uh is the website where you
[ __ ] go to and you join up and every
month they send you a box underwear I
mean it's like having a mom who goes to
the store for you to buy you underwear
but who buys you the best on do I'm
gonna take it one step further you lose
your mother ever this will replace her
there's a sauna ban like my mom didn't
buy my underwear my dad did and my dad's
dead but signing up to me and he's calm
is almost like rising my father from the
grave with a reading of the Knepper
Necronomicon if only they could also
Mira not much around easy [ __ ] yeah so I
was normally done I mean here kind of
they really gender divided in laughs my
mom would buy my my sister's on these
but my dad always bloodline
yeah I'm really [ __ ] subject to his
purity professors briefing the breech
man of the starchy breeze man so we're
all [ __ ] starchy briefs I'm still
fruit illuminant your little the undies
comes along and said here just like a
[ __ ] modern man you [ __ ] crow mag
it was just me and my brother so my mom
was buying Underpants for us anyway
right but we have a very lacy taste look
where these are right did you ever go to
school in like panties instead of
underwear I know I do
no new underwear moms like wear these I
was like these are Virginia's and she
was like I know just don't tell anybody
they felt yeah it so sexy I mean yeah
little too sexy
almost exeunt as the underwear from me
on these calm what is this [ __ ] made of
it's a fabric that comes from literally
the planet Santa guard base fabric
called Space Age polymer involve homo
down I think it is that's right motel
why would i troll the universe but not
design only for underwear underwear
loveliness it's comfy as [ __ ] man this
is here let me get rid of the legalese
do it for a limited time everyone in my
audience in his audience as well our
audience they get 20% off their first
order but you have to go to our special
page URL me Indies comm @m e un di es
comm slash fat man all one word and
stuff like that they got a guaranteed
you got nothing to loose if you don't
like it you can [ __ ] it send it back
then they'll give you your money back
like these cats are [ __ ] crazy man
they sell them on the second-hand on the
web market and then the end some people
are like panty sniffers they are motels
you're right three times softer than
cotton have you ever said what the [ __ ]
is softer the cotton and thought I don't
know a cloud you were wrong
dreams rolled out just for the sport of
the children's tears something cotton
that's but not here they these good
folks to me on these comment discovered
something softer and less heartbreaking
than your child's tears it is the fabric
from which they make the [ __ ]
Underpants to the price of two cocktails
yep [ __ ] drunks you could get me on
these pee and these calm deliver your
favorite new pair underwear right to
your doorstep just your deck instantly
brightens it doesn't like it like it's
like somebody's blowing gently warmly on
your junk all day long it is being most
delightful feeling and as a bunch of
designs - so it's like a bunch of
different people blowing on your junk
all day yeah
ghosts blowing on your junk you don't
want to hours go by underwear you know
what you need time for you manga play
video games for
go out he'd go to Netflix you want me
getting up gonna buy underwear don't
know me undies dot-com will treat you
like a baby should be treated pampered
in underpants just dropship that [ __ ]
right to your house like operation Dumbo
drop instead of elephants underwear they
send you so much [ __ ] underwear they
like you don't even have to when you're
done wearing at once you can be like
fling out the window and [ __ ] and you
can live like a rockstar then they'll
fly to space join their planetary body
back to the like we have me information
to the planet vote out me a nice calm
supportive Sean that you [ __ ] as you
watch this show man I'm telling you
ladies men children boys it's all
everything that everyone by everyone
everybody needs somebody know someone
love this is a business you won't
[ __ ] find a better offer than this
today man go to me and ease calm slash
fat man and get on the [ __ ] me on
this train do it like uh wear it like a
champ Jen Sean [ __ ] can't wrap
your dick or quit in modal like the man
that's in their new slogan I like that
for free me undies calm their dick in
modal [ __ ] slash [ __ ] and most people
driving home look at the bill boy look
whose mobile love to alright man now
that we're done cursing and [ __ ]
talking about Underpants let's review a
children's me and March saw Lego Batman
movie yes we did I thought at the
premiere I went by myself
ah but it was the inner school playing
[ __ ] so that I went and they had like
she's supposed to go with me and they
had like Harley Quinn Smith and I was
like one please go off red Malcolm
Ingram at the movies one cruise but it
was didn't matter
I didn't need a [ __ ] kid that's how
good that movie is that movie makes you
go why did I have children don't need
them yeah this movie makes up for any
sort of like you know should I pass on
this legacy [ __ ] no because you'll never
make anything if you have a thousand
babies
you'll never make one as good as this
Batman like Lego Batman movie I had a
great time and I didn't expect to like
it as much as I did to be honest with
you right what what soured you going
back soured but I was that lego movie it
[ __ ] perfection it's magic it is
absolute [ __ ] magic and I had no
expectations of that lego movie
whatsoever is going well come on lego
movie and it is it is one of the 20
greatest things ever [ __ ] created by
human and such a wonderful movie makes
you feel good and [ __ ] makes you hopeful
funniest [ __ ] and Batman was an amazing
character as depicted annual darkness no
parents like really funny but you know
one character on the journey and no
supporting player so when they were like
we're gonna make a whole movie about
that naturally they got my money I'm
gonna go but I didn't expect they could
touch what they did with the lego movie
and for me they did they they were able
to tell you the story of isolation of a
person is just like no I got this I got
this
who needs to learn how to work well with
other kids movie first and foremost
right that being said for me best Batman
movie I saw on a theater since the Dark
Knight the structure of a Batman movie
that it has is wonderful like and the
fact that it's full Batman family like
you see condiment King if you're if
you're a DC Comics nut not everyone is
but even if you're like I'm a spoke of
Marvel zombie [ __ ] you the chances are
you love Batman you know a little bit
totally there ain't no Marvel [ __ ]
zombie on the planets like I don't do
Batman like everybody does Batman
Batman's everybody's a little [ __ ] so
if you know Batman you know the world
about man you know a little bit of DC
this movie has a gazillion jokes they
just whip out for free like just hitting
constantly works as a DC if you're a DC
fan works on that level insanely well
works on the level of a kid's movie of
like hey there's a nice little less than
them and you know I've made it through I
wasn't like where's the popcorn [ __ ] I
was gripped the whole time and also
works as a [ __ ] Batman movies Batman
fan I was like oh my god this is like a
[ __ ] Batman fan film made by a fan of
every incarnation of Batman which is
like all of us so I I went I went in
going like I'm sure we find I went out
what a magic trick that was like you
know what a party that was wonderful
it was like they all had a party in my
mouth and I came that doesn't sound good
was like in my head and [ __ ] what is
your take it away the thing that I loved
about this movie and I was not as
overwhelmingly like through the moon let
me fill my mouth with spit so I could do
that um I love that it incorporated and
streamlined and put on a rail that the
last 60 years of Batman screen
continuity is the same thing awesome but
like the Adam West years and be like
somebody makes a joke about remember
when you would try to take over Gotham
with a prince music is in that the Joker
yeah just right like the fact that Billy
Dee Williams is playing to faith they
have enough Batman movies to be able to
make Batman movie jokes
yeah you know it reminded me a bit of
Mark Waid Runner and daredevil which
does this thing where and of course
Daedalus had tons of incarnations over
the years his his son
super dark super bright super light
super [ __ ] grim and it's not that it
was different takes on it was all one
story according to Mark Waid and
daredevil Matt Murdock had made a
decision to not be grim so for his run
he was going to be fun because the
alternative was [ __ ] insanity but
this movie makes a decision to make it
all one continuity yeah which is [ __ ]
brilliant the thing that I was missing
though was that in the lego movie the
movie itself is both super fun on the
surface but it's got this super great
sort of lessening morale underneath it
the idea that fathers and sons in order
and chaos and creativity is not
something to be you know stamped down
and nothing to be eradicated but it's
actually something to be embraced and
where this world is alive because of
creativity and they may you try and SAP
it from that with the kragle which makes
everything firm and hard is is this
great discussion about age and
discussion about sort of moral
flexibility and mental flexibility where
this movie was families awesome you're
absolutely right you know which I don't
decry in any way as a message but it
didn't it didn't do for me what either
the lego movie did or The Incredibles
does which is also maybe the best
superhero movie ever made getting a
sequel getting a sequel like also a kids
movie also functions the exact
the way you know a kids movie needs to
there's enough Wow Big Ben whatever but
you also get the aging of it you get the
man who needs to feel like you still has
a part in the world
the wife who feels like a family
spending apart kids who don't ever get
the love from their parents right all of
these things are synthesized into this
perfect fantastic four story I was just
missing that thing it sounds like you
saw the bat Lego Batman movie that I was
expecting to see right and maybe because
I will might well I'm not nearly smart
and also my expectations were lower I
went out like I went in gone yeah I'm
surely fine I went out go on about a
magic trick
I feel so [ __ ] good inside but you're
right like I'd certainly still doff my
cap or cowl if you will uh to the lego
movie like it is you're right it is a
synthesis of so many different stories
yeah whereas this you're right this was
very much like Toby and I can add that
important it is super enjoyable and
entertaining and all the Dames Oaks are
all annex I was fantastic but I just
wanted more to the gooey Center more
nougaty instead of more crunchy don't
know what that means I was uh I was
wholly satisfied I was like more of this
[ __ ] keep it coming over I really
liked I they done Barbara Gordon as the
Commissioner in the comics ever spoilers
I don't not that I know what a great
idea that's amazing like you know
Commissioner Gordon fisherman Gordon
retires and Commissioner Gordon is
Barbara Gordon in this version of Law
topit isms in this regard make her feel
good but uh but what I liked about it
was she wasn't that girl yeah she just
wanted you that she's the same she
wanted to you know stop crime but
through the justice system do it right
and they were less depending less on
Batman and you know Batman deal but we
don't want man yes oh
and so just great take on the character
rosario Dawson boys perfect wonderful
and then the incarnation of like you
gotta wear suit because the whole time
I'm like you know they put her in ads as
Batgirl but like you get to like the
last two
the movie she stole Barbara Gordon and
then to get her into the suit you're out
there and it's it's why it's adorable
um I've seen this movie yes I'm sure
where was about yeah yeah yeah bout six
months ago
what what yeah I saw a mash of that like
literally off-camera Williams up I did
it was a catch meaning because I live I
live in the part of Los Angeles which
has it's deep in the valley and it's the
the perfect sort of demographic
cross-section where for the rest of
America so they catch clean a bunch of
movies here so I kind of rolled in with
my kid probably like October of last
year maybe did not tell them I was a
member of the press otherwise I would
have had to leave right and I'd had to
like slink in my seat once I say hey
this Geoff Johns and then there's
there's all this Jeff Robin off and
there's all of like Warner Brothers but
Brad Ryman tsujihara and half of them
know what I look like and I should not
be in the screening so just take the boy
put him on my lap nobody will see me
like who's old enough that baby like a
human shield
that's weird I guess far from her but
yeah it was not even a half rendered
like you saw the first half of it sort
of mostly CG and by the back half
hitches drawings on paper or ten voices
and so part of me seeing it the second
time was where did they fill in the
blanks what about where where did they
realize you're related comparison a
little a b2c all right what did it used
to be what was it going to be like the
Phantom Zone was kind of totally
different there was a giant robot was
the bed phantom zone person I don't
think they've had the clearances for
stuff like the Daleks yet another who
did they do well I mean when they did
the hey we're going to expand the
universe I noticed it was like Harry
Potter which Warner brother says Wizard
of Oz which I think Warner Brothers
what else would Sauron form or the Rings
which is new line water but one of us
has but I think that Doctor Who that was
the one that was like how does one of
those have that and they get it because
the same thing for the first leg of the
movie they had the rights to everything
Lego has the rights to the Lego has
playsets
star wars and you know the Marvel stuff
even and you know they've got everything
so they could put them all into a movie
without having to overly go around and
make bargains with the devil to get
stuff from as a nice touch turn as a
nice - see ya like I still like this you
saw the work-in-progress the whip way I
call it so and then I saw the finished
product and it is amazing but you can do
that sort of thing you know even in six
months to finish a movie like that and a
- it are jokes and completely we
engineer what the Phantom Zone would
look like I mean how to him [ __ ] I uh
where do you give if we were great and I
want [ __ ] grades you figure it out okay
you'll go Sam nobody doesn't like this
movie yeah it is [ __ ] so worth your
time like you didn't hear a [ __ ] yay
nay you heard like oh my god doug is big
and this guy's like it's cool it's cool
handshake will do either way maybe it's
a handy either were there go he's
sucking on even better either way it's a
must it's a it's a do yeah I give you a
Batman fan there's no way you don't get
all of the joy out of this movie do what
I do anybody know number 155 million I
think over the weekend it beats fifty
shades darker really yeah domestically I
mean um well don't throw that in so this
is the message fun live in America
that's what chimera first I've been
hearing a lot lately that's what it has
to do is I believe is the box office
numbers make Batman great again so he's
always been desert so okay well that's
hard I don't know you know I'm certainly
not wishing the other thing well but
it's nice to know that yeah Batman is
still preferred to I mean I think that
50 shaded Christian Grey because fifty
shades of gray the first one open Bruce
Wayne Meador billionaire
sexier billionaire one could argue than
Christian Grey yeah you're right first
one open life personally like 110
million dollars and he didn't have a
Batman movie again no and they were
expecting at the money geyser okay
alright now I date my house like a
mushroom show him your [ __ ] we're
challenged
not everybody neither of the or a good
sign
but yeah so that made fifty five I think
fifty shades darker made like forty five
and then John wick dude made thirty
million that that's one wrong for John
wick negra yeah I mean the first one
cost twenty made like sixty and then
this one cost twenty five saw wick and
you like the wick we're gonna talk about
in the next w-well yes that's right
that's all you're gonna get about Lego
Batman go see the [ __ ] out of it
Will Arnett genius voice-over artist but
I love Minh everything yeah Michael Cera
was wonderful and fun and touching as
Robin ores areas we said just meant as
the kid used to say refine as Alfred who
did not voice Baltimore yeah Eddie
Izzard voices Vulcan rip told him with
um yeah for some reason I thought that
was a shoo-in yeah like must be in but
he didn't believe double duty make it
pay twice so funny but he was a
fantastic outlet um what else like
Ralph's Tennant Ralph Garman does voices
now Dana Chris Hardwick isn't it
how did you feel about Jack Nelson a
kisses Joker I could find like funny
like you know if I can steal the show
but that's it's so hard to do that
character though like if you're going to
you either have to steer so far away
from what Mark Hamill does that it
doesn't feel like the Joker right or you
have to lean so much into what Mark
Hamill does but it feels like a copy
mark Hamill's Joker it's definitely well
they had people come in and do you know
in the Dark Knight cartoon movie the guy
from person of interest from lost right
he did the Joker and you know he didn't
he went for something else like it you
know the guy was in Kevin who did know
well obviously remembers but the guy who
did a bad the Joker
during the Batman cartoon which was like
more like sounded it was like the you
know he's you know very different take
it's possible to do a different
it just didn't I thought it was noble of
him to stay out of the way you know what
I'm saying rather than make it about him
and look out [ __ ] and I'm not saying
like he was the funny
he had funny moments even but the
character was played in a wonderfully
different way too so you know does it
sound like I'm not like I'm gonna try I
hope it didn't sound like I'm making
excuses for him but he wasn't the yeah
like this joke he was he was strong but
it wasn't like oh my god
he'd redefined the character yeah like
he wasn't going from manic he's going
for heartbroken yeah I guess that's what
so much of that story that worked its
erm and I didn't bump into it at one
moment and go like they should have
gotten somebody else yeah and I do like
to be a bit and they put in the
advertising of scene of you know him
being like I fight around and like how
he keeps gone like you mean nothing to
me and blah blah blah and they keep
cutting back his eyes they're getting
bored because your water a wonderful bit
but just tell me you hate me I dislike
you intensely just say it I tried around
um it's it's absolute magic hats off to
all involved man yes that's Graham
Greene Jim Smith Graham Smith is that in
him Seth grahame-smith Graham Greene is
Michael an American actor
I call myself Kevin Green from Seth
grahame-smith who wrote the Abraham
Lincoln vampire killer yet movie and
Pride and Prejudice and Zombies surprise
he did that as well
he wrote the book he wrote the movie I
think he did both he wrote this I mean
there's a couple different writers but
he brought you this was his screen and
his story and then there's nine people
got credit like what a dream job that
was I thought they I thought like it
played like a love letter to Batman I've
zero complaints about that script I'm
not like they should they shouldn't not
know they were more imaginative than I
would have dared be you know they oh I
wonder if that script is what got him
the flash job which he had been later
lost I know we could find out we could
get him on the show
he'll if internet couple ask him stuff
Graham Smith rape there's room for three
yeah but hats off to all involve all new
directors redirected
McKay who was an editor on the first one
on the lego movie yet wonderful job
magic there it is folks for Batman
Batman I'm Kevin Smith and I'm mark
barnard come back next episode we're
going to talk about other things
yeah Oh a John wick and [ __ ] me same
bat-time same bat-channel so I guess
calm or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
you